there is a new poll of ohio voters
done by the right-leaning rasmussen
reports which has donald trump losing by
four points to joe biden 49 to 45 and
this is a really important
poll for a few different reasons first
of all is ohio
ohio is of such importance to
republicans and in fact republicans
a republican presidential candidate has
not won the electoral college
without winning ohio dating back decades
you have to go at least to the 70s
and i didn't go back any further than
that so it republicans need ohio
historically in order to win
even more so than i would even say
florida
ohio is one of those states where if
trump does not win ohio
it could be a very very bad election for
donald trump
this is also an important poll because
it's a rasmussen poll and rasmussen
polls tend to lean right
uh if even a rasmussen poll says trump
is losing ohio by four
that could also be very bad for trump
however
you might say this is only one poll
donald trump certainly is still winning
ohio overall right
not so fast in fact in the real clear
politics
average of recent polling joe biden is
up by 2.4
on average right now in ohio that
includes
an ohio media collaborative poll from
six weeks ago which had joe biden
winning
there's a poll between that one and the
rasmussen poll
which has donald trump up by one so it
is certainly
true that there's not as much polling
data out of ohio as there is from some
other states
it is absolutely a fact that we should
not get cocky or arrogant
in any way but this is much like
you know when we look at donald trump
being up by only two in texas according
to the recent dallas
morning news poll when you look at
the numbers out of places like arizona
these are signals about how the election
could go
if we vote if we that's all it is these
are when i see a poll
i see it as an opportunity and it
actually
would make a lot of sense if ohio went
to joe biden
it would make sense because ohio has
been absolutely ravaged by donald
trump's tariffs on china
which i know you all understand this
trump doesn't seem to
when you place tariffs on chinese
products
american businesses importing those
products
pay the tariffs it's not the chinese who
pay the tariffs
when you're in manufacturing when you're
in farming and you're dealing with
counter tariffs from china ohio is a
place
that would be very much affected by
donald trump's disastrous trade policy
the point here is
every state has to be involved we're
going to deal with this in today's
voicemail in fact
i'm continuing to experience worry
that some people aren't getting the
importance of every state
being involved here but think about it
this way if donald trump is really up by
only two in texas
make him fight for the win make him
spend money
in texas that he won't have other places
we talked yesterday about how donald
trump has already spent 73 percent of
the 1.1 billion dollars that he's raised
since the start of 2019. trump is in a
cash crunch trump is struggling to
continue running ads
in all of the states in which he should
be running ads make him spend money to
defend texas
if florida is tied or bidens up a little
in florida or
trump is up a little in florida the
point is florida is in play
and any money that trump spends in
florida is money he cannot spend
in ohio that's good for joe biden the
whole point here is
we have to run up the score in every
state while
simultaneously keeping the pressure up
so trump actually has to fight for
states that in past elections
republicans
didn't have to put any money into that
would have been easy wins for
republicans
that's the way to do it one other great
example of this is arizona
arizona has been a red state for a long
time
and in presidential elections and on
average
joe biden is currently winning by five
including winning by
nine in arizona in a recent fox news
poll martha mcsally the republican
incumbent senator in arizona is down by
as much as
17 to democratic senate challenger mark
kelly
it tells us nothing other than the state
is in play and it's worth fighting for
if only to make donald trump himself
have to fight for it that
in itself helps joe biden let's keep it
going
we're down to just seven plus weeks
remaining here
we're going to keep the pressure up we
need you to keep the pressure up as well
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video